i miss you
so much
andy circus and venom literally became
voices inside of tom hardy's ear on set
for venom let there be carnage from
circus imitating venom on set to
orchestrating
650 extras during the rave scene filming
of the second venom movie was seriously
intense then evolves into a physical
altercation carnage grabbing is one of
the most epic scenes and behind the
scenes was no different rigged up with
wires and harnesses all the motions were
mimicked and the actor was spun about in
the air and when it was time for cgi to
work its magic effects took over and
filled in where carnage should be to
help bring the right vibes on set a
large claw was also around to help block
where the cgi would appear
when eddie and venom begin their major
brawl the apartment becomes absolute
chaos with furniture and objects flying
everywhere this was actually all
captured live on set the creative team
had their work cut out for them as they
tied up all the objects that got thrown
which literally flew out of the flew out
of the window with string in order to
achieve the effects we see in the film
as for hardy's stunt double jacob tamori
was rigged up to harnesses and literally
smashed around into furniture andy
circus has so much experience working
with cgi characters and as an actor
himself that he couldn't help but jump
in on occasion and direct tom hardy
while performing hardy's parts himself
getting into the character's head as the
director was an important aspect for
circus because venom's dialogue was
constantly changing so the actor
director duo could riff off each other
and find new lines at this point andy
comes out with some very good
impressions
the team had to make sure they filmed
all the options they might need before
the movie went into the editing stage so
they could have enough material to play
with what didn't make the final cut were
the many sometimes questionable venom
impressions behind the scenes that's
stoic you have a stoic all right mine's
a little bit more
the rave scene in venom let there be
carnage is incredible with all the
lights puppets and action and pulling it
off was a pretty exciting feat
the scene was written into the script
but pretty loosely so director andy
serkis was able to go into filming with
an open mind and play around with the
actors and creative team with a whopping
650 extras on set the energy was high
and definitely helped with the flow of
the sequence immensely the environment
was made to be pretty remarkable with
the giant puppets brought in and
extensive colorful lights it was
definitely easy for the actors to
imagine and perform a major party it was
always going to be a kind of carnival
day of the damned kind of all night of
the damn sort of festival tom hardy gave
his all no matter whether the cameras
were rolling or they were just
rehearsing a scene when he had to
perform his big apartment fight as eddie
brock against venom hardy often
vocalized any injury pretty intensely
he'd literally go up
even though hardy obviously wasn't
battling him in person the actor would
react and make sounds as if he were hit
totally convincing he's been in an
actual fight the voice of venom was
always in tom hardy's head quite
literally since the actor was performing
his scenes opposite venom alone before
getting to set hardy recorded every
single one of the lines and then using
earbuds listened to all of venom's
dialogue as they came and he could
respond in real time this meant the
actor also felt able to improvise
talking over venom and really bringing
magic to the scene with the help of this
sneaky trick hardy was able to
differentiate and really give a life to
both characters in some cases the sound
team would record his lines in the
morning and then when filming play them
back so he could perform that way we
have a feeling these scenes made a lot
more sense for the team watching when it
wasn't just tom hardy hearing venom
andy circus was pretty creative and
hands-on when directing the second venom
film going so far is to become a little
voice in lead actor tom hardy's head
since the actor already had an earpiece
tucked away so he could hear venom's
lines circus would occasionally pop onto
the mic and give him directions live
during the middle of scenes this meant
at any time hardy could suddenly get
blocking directions while performing the
fact that he excelled in this is just a
testament to how gifted a performer he
is
by the time the venom let there be
carnage team finished filming the
apartment battle it looked like a
tornado had come through while they
could have used cgi to show how
destroyed the apartment gets a
combination of the editing and practical
effects were used to help authentically
portray the wild sequence we wanted to
literally physically smash that place up
at one point venom's tongue was played
by a green foam bat and chickens get
thrown about which aren't real chickens
those chickens we see in the kitchen
with eddie brock and venom
those are real
except for the ones that get injured
that is
not to worry no birds were harmed in the
making while it's definitely easier to
manage and handle cgi birds as opposed
to the real thing the team lucked out
with their surprisingly unfussy unmessy
and very professional chickens
the perfect chickens to work with while
tom hardy did perform a ton of his own
stunts and fights in the film he did
have a stunt double who stepped in to
take over when the scene was too
dangerous or could injure hardy in the
process the eddie venom actor was
particularly at risk since he'd had two
knee operations only eight weeks before
filming
this meant jacob tomorry took the reins
when eddie needed to be thrown through a
wall or leaping through windows
before filming even began jacob tamari
would often check in with hardy to see
what his weight was at so he could try
to match the physique when he had to
double him on screen
since he couldn't match hardy's
physicality completely tamari actually
wears what's called a trap suit which is
essentially muscle padding for his
shoulders
let's just say very few people were fans
of woody harrelson's wig in the first
venom
including woody harrelson the red really
was just a strange choice thankfully it
was out with the old and he was given a
new less intensely colored wig that
worked out much better in this film
every detail had to be thought of to
ensure the cgi in the film came across
as realistically as possible when
bringing venom to the screen details
like the colors tom hardy wore made a
big impact in this lighting we can see
that hardy's burnt orange bathrobe looks
quite dark offering the perfect space
for venom to emerge from and so in fact
that affects costume even choices of
costume color without attention being
paid to these seemingly insignificant
details we wouldn't get the incredible
visuals we see in the final cut
when it came to the motorcycle scenes
hardy performed some of the moments but
when the requirements became too risky a
stunt specialist with precision riding
skills took over the speedy scenes
all of this was performed on an upgrade
of what eddie wrote in the first venom
film he's still on a ducati but a ducati
panigale also known as a superbike is
his ride of choice in this movie the
original bike was specifically chosen
for its more rugged look and because of
how it could perform certain stunts
not a detail gets overlooked with this
crew
it's no wonder tom hardy tells the story
as eddie and venom so well since he
actually had a part in writing it this
is the actor's first writing credit and
the whole process definitely helped him
with getting into his character and
understanding how to portray the scenes
so it's just making up stories really
and problem solving venom is a film with
tons of passion humor and special
effects all of which comes together to
bring us yet another fantastic film
about this anti-hero we are seriously
impressed with just how innovative the
creative team was